breaking Senate minority leader Mitch
McConnell calls it a mistake for Tucker
Carlson and Fox News to release the
never-before-seen j6 footage let me play
for you this short clip it was a mistake
in my view for
Fox News to depict this
in a way that's completely at variance
with what our chief law enforcement
official here at Capitol thanks well
that's Mitch McConnell back in the blue
right there babe that's what it's called
back in the blue and then Elon Musk
responded I keep forgetting which party
he belongs to and Charlie Kirk emails it
he says you in a party
yeah that's basically it so uh as as
many of you know we got this footage
released I think it's uh it's very
important it shows that the Q Shaman
actually let me see if I can just pull
up the video footage I know we showed it
last night but for those that missed it
I want you all to see this so you can
show your friends and your family the
people who don't believe you the Q
Shaman being escorted by police through
the building who make no attempt
whatsoever to stop him and not only do
they make no attempt to stop him they
actually try to open doors for him how
are you going to charge someone with
unlawful entry or trespassing or
parading or whatever when you when
you're escorting him through the
building and opening door look at this
here he is walking through a a mob of
police officers who don't care at all
literally don't care here we go right
this way sir here you are and then sure
enough when he goes in he says thank you
to the heavenly father for taking the
inspiration needed to these police
officers to allow us into the building
there you go there it is
chansley understood that Capitol Police
were his allies video shows him giving
thanks for them in a prayer on the floor
of the Senate watch
to allow us into the building you know
they they let these people in the
building and Mitch McConnell he's mad it
was a mistake the American people get to
see this footage of the Capitol Police
helping these people he says it's
completely at variance with what the
police had said maybe the police were
lying because if you really want to
believe the Insurrection narrative they
were in on it that's what AOC thinks
I tweeted j6 was an inside job and left
got real mad at me but pick one did you
get kicked off Twitter No but maybe
maybe look I'll say this to the to
liberals the Democrats
you got to pick one either the police
let these people in and there was no
Insurrection or the Capitol Police were
a part of the Insurrection and we're in
on the whole time can I just tell you
one thing that people might get ticked
off at I'm glad that the videotape
footage is getting out there but I don't
think it's the consequential piece of
evidence that we need to see right now
from the FBI to doj to answer the
question you posed you mean the
consequential or you don't think it's
consequential at all to answer the
consequential question right whether or
not that you just posed I think as a
former Federal prosecutor and a public
defender who defended a lot of these
types of cases
what you need to show is whether or not
the FBI and government agents were using
undercover operatives and informants on
the day of January 6 because if you can
show that you know they've been at hang
on but the paperwork shows having run
informants that's a six-month build up
minimum right minimum it's not like they
just dropped them into the proud boys
and said hey don't disrupt please so
once you prove that then you defeat the
Insurrection narrative with the FBI's
own documentation forget what the
videotape shows just just for for people
who you can't see what's going on in the
room the reason why cash just said hang
on or whatever is because I started
smirking and rolling my eyes and what I
meant to convey with that is come on we
know they were involved
no look I totally clarify though I'm not
saying I know definitively what I'm
saying is a reasonable suspicion is that
there were agents there's a video
showing a guy with an earpiece pulling
people into the building all right you
combine that with the evidence of right
apps and it looks like you have a
preponderance of evidence suggesting
there may have been federal law
enforcement involved in making that
thing happen I'll get you beyond A
Reasonable Doubt two pieces of
information Ray Epps was on FBI's most
wanted list one day and the next day he
was off of the FBI's most wanted list
there are only two ways that happens you
die
or your informant put that aside under
Congressional testimony Jill Sanborn who
I used to work with the head of the FBI
counterintelligence division in charge
of all these investigations testified
under oath when Senator Cruz asked her
spent flat out were their federal agents
involved with January 6 and she said
quote Senator I can't answer that at
this time not if the answer was
definitively no having been a doj FBI
guy myself she would have gone there and
said nope absolutely not the reason she
said I can't answer that is because of
the same stonewalling they gave us
during resturgate with Christopher
Steele Helper and everybody else it's
the same narrative and opportunity they
were there so you're saying that she
said I can't answer that because the
answer is yes and that would compromise
whatever their operation was exactly is
I mean what's the argument they make
that she just didn't know when she
didn't want to say yes or no
definitively there is no way the head of
the FBI counterintelligence division the
number three ranking person at the FBI
who is in charge of the January 6th
investigations did not know the answer
to that it is not possible
sounds like the answer is yes Matt Gates
came out over a year ago saying that
there was I think that there was
evidence of federal involvement I
believe yeah here's the other thing just
follow the money everybody wants to know
about all the spycraft and all the cool
stuff you know what the FBI has to do to
these informants pay them you know what
that requires a bank go find out what's
what we did with steel right and I got
tortured for it I went to Paul Ryan I
said give me this one subpoena and if
I'm wrong you can fire me and he
basically tried to fire me anyway wow
but then I went and got the FBI records
and the bank that paid them and then the
floodgates opened game over they said
there's no way we used informants to
investigate the fisa and Donald Trump
and all this crap well if they did it
then are you telling me they really
didn't do it now yeah maybe they pay
with crypto
maybe that's true and also I just kind
of I want to say especially right now if
you Google search this story the media
response is hilarious they're like
what's the thing I didn't oh just every
single story is like they're lying about
uh what Tucker Carlson said right one of
the first things Tucker Carlson says in
this report is we've all seen the
violence and he shows video of the
violence they've shown us this over and
over again what they're not telling you
is that there's another portion with a
permanent peaceful rally that were LED
in by police and that's not a part of
their narrative what they're doing now
is they're claiming that Tucker only
said it was peaceful because they
project they they claim they they claim
that the right does what they in fact
are doing all the time it's it's it's
remarkable that if you're paying
attention to news if you are a
Discerning individual like most people
watching this show you can see it
happening like Ukraine gate for instance
Joe Biden is on camera
engaging in a quid pro admitting to a
quid pro quo unless you do what I demand
I will withhold federally guaranteed
loans to your country which he has no
authority to do
and then when Donald Trump tries to
investigate it they accuse him of doing
literally the same thing they were
caught doing so in in this instance
Tucker Carlson comes out and says let me
let me be nuanced yeah there was
violence those people are committing
vandalism they're attacking cops they'll
be prosecuted these people were peaceful
and the Democrats lied about it so what
are the Democrats in the media corporate
press do they lie and claim Tucker is
only telling you it was peaceful
and here's how you see that yeah well
how do you solve it put it all out for
everybody yeah the problem is I wonder
if the quest it's a question of the
I don't know the the intellectual
capabilities of of the of the people
between you know political parties or
whatever well is it is I wonder if the
divide in politics are uh perspicacious
individuals and cogs zombies NPCs you
mean in putting this out I mean the
decision to put this out rests with the
house no I mean in terms of the left and
the right oh is the left predominantly
followers and the right is predominantly
Discerning individuals I don't know the
answer to that I think you just got to
play the videotape and put it all out
there and let the online salutes do what
they do which is but I just get it but
you you take a look at what the response
on the corporate press is it's lying no
no I'm not disagreeing with you but
that's that's not new well sure sure
what I mean to say is are there people
who just lack the the capabilities to
watch the video you put out or will
their demoralized brains not allow them
to process that information as per your
bestmanov I think it's a combination of
two I think after six or seven years of
this some people just don't have the
capacity to process that something like
that could happen I think a lot of other
people will quietly in their little
group say okay we know that that
happened but when we go to the
microphones we have to say x yeah how
much of this 44 000 hours you think is
defect
I think look here's here's here's how
the security footage works right in the
capital having worked there a lot of it
is just going to be dead time like empty
rooms showing office furniture
probably half of it to be honest with
you so now we're down to like 21 000
hours of footage still a ton of footage
right but that's I think 17 hours of
footage 17 000 hours of footage 1 700
days of footage so just to put in
perspective on how much it takes to
digest all that and I guess AI they're
able to use AI to split out all the
footage of non-motion so they can just
discard that I'm concerned that it's
going to defeat the Q Shaman not him
obviously he's a little too public but
deep fake people blowing things up or
destroying things when they weren't I
mean obviously that's a malicious as
hell but I can hey don't count it out
you know we live in the United States
any they're capable of anything the one
thing the left and some of the media and
I hate to say they had a piece of it
right but the one thing they are saying
which I have to agree with is that there
are portions of some of the people that
we're saying we're totally innocent
where there's actually videotape of them
doing something illegal like trespassing
per the criminal statutes or interfering
with police officers so that's going to
be the problem that if you do person by
person like you do the Q whatever this
guy's name is I don't think Chancellor I
don't think Tucker should have started
with that guy he should have picked some
guy that was straight up innocent looked
at all the videotape on that one guy
found out he was charged with something
you should never been charged with and
then started with him this guy is just
too divisive of a character to do that
with because I'm sure the left's gonna
come back and say hey check out this
video and I don't know if this is true
but check out this video of him you know
kicking a cop in the or something I
don't think there's anything of that I
think the only footage that ever showed
is him just walking through and yelling
the bullhorn
but it's the it's the it's the
iconography okay the weird hat thing
that he's wearing the face paint that's
why they they targeted him I think
you're onto something with that I think
the iconography of that of that day they
really really want the memes to be that
the at least for the left they wanted
the memes to be that it was a violent
you know serious thing anytime I talk
about it it's not odd that I get you
know pictures of that that miniature
um noose that they put up the miniature
Gallows the he wasn't even full size but
people on the left still think that that
Gallows was real and that was a real
threat and stuff so I think I think the
mean thing is totally right yeah I just
looked Jacob chancelly up just searched
for him on Brave and a group of some you
know three of the top 10 photos or him
screaming
like that's the that's the image I think
a lot of people are looking for is him
going ah yeah yeah yeah now you know if
you scream I think if they show
trespassing like non-violent offenses
they've served time that's time served
get them out immediately get them out if
they showed a picture of like some 50
year old dude with a big beer belly
holding a little American flag and
wiggling it and holding his baby in his
arms or something well I don't know if
he had babies with him but there's like
some some big fat guy just like waving
an American flag it doesn't it doesn't
have that same kind of vibe of some dude
with a crazy thing like that did anybody
take kids in that day
I don't think so probably though I mean
I would be surprised a lot of these
people were at a peaceful rally on the
other side of the building that had a
permit to be there and the police opened
the doors and let them in and Alex Jones
is yelling stop don't do it don't go in
the building if they're obsessed with
blaming innocent people for Crime
they're gonna lose it's going to lose it
can't it's not something why do you say
I'm not so convinced because it's all
the data is coming out it's becoming
apparent like people are making fun of
them on the news with the people on the
left are doubling down and saying that
Tucker's lying that they're that it's
wrong blah blah blah and the average
Normie that doesn't watch a lot of this
stuff that has maybe you know an hour a
week that they can commit to actually
paying attention to what's going on in
politics they're still going to get
their news from MSNBC or CNN or whatever
and so I don't know that it's guaranteed
that just because this stuff comes out
your average person that is you know a
normie is going to be significantly
swayed now I hope that I'm wrong but I
don't see any real reason to believe
that this information
is really new you know I mean it's like
these are things that people thought and
assumed before I don't think that just
because there's confirmation on video I
don't think that your average soccer mom
in southern Connecticut is like oh man
I'm talking about I will support their
investigation if they let the innocent
people go if there are people blowing
breaking windows and kicking cops I want
them to serve Justice for that so they
want I'll join them and they're they're
Crusade if they let the innocent people
go this is why I was saying this moment
ago that I wonder if what really does
separate the political factions in this
country is
cognitive faculties
oh yeah McConnell was talking so slow in
that video earlier it's not just that's
like normalized it's it's you have
people who believe literally anything
the media says and no matter how many
times they're proven to be liars and
wrong they just keep doubling down and
I'm like that's a certain level of
zombism yeah that you know a lack of
higher brain function you know like if
someone comes to you and says do you
want to stick a gum and then you're like
why yes I certainly would and when you
pull it out it snaps your finger with
those little prank traps they have and
you go well that kind of hurt that was a
dick move then you go here take another
piece of gum and then you go I don't
mind if I do snap ow man stop doing that
well do you want gum for real time yes I
certainly do but at a certain point it's
like what's wrong with you no he's just
gonna snap your finger again you're not
wrong there's still people who think
that we went into Iraq because there
were wmds there that's literally never
going to change for a certain faction of
the populace even though years later it
was proven definitively that that wasn't
even the case it wasn't even remotely
the case there are people that still
believe Donald Trump defended white
nationalists in the United I think it
was a Mark Twain he's also a Russian
asset don't forget that there was a guy
who went on MSNBC and argued that Donald
Trump was a Soviet asset like the Soviet
Union doesn't even exist right right
that was my favorite I I was it Jonathan
I enjoyed it to be to be to be fair what
he said was that Trump may have been an
asset of the Russian since the 80s which
would imply he was an asset of the
Soviet Union and after in the 80s and
after the Soviet Union collapsed the
infrastructure of Russia maintained him
as a as an asset for their uh that's my
favorite fan fiction that is my favorite
comic book story can you can we do like
we need a skit where Donald Trump is
like talking and then someone
accidentally says the activation code
and then Trump starts speaking Russian
yeah like someone that can do can you
imagine Donald Trump doing the uh yeah
yeah someone they can do a really good
Donald Trump imitation but speaking
purely in Russian
Trump in Russian yeah in Russian but
doing the important thing yeah
Mark Twain has this quote it's easier to
fool people than to convince them
they've been fooled yeah and he's a
smart he was a smart dude there's
there's there's a risk that like all
this information doesn't convince people
it just makes them say well I want to
pay less attention you know it's if you
make them feel stupid they'll withdraw
so you got to do it in a way that people
kind of empowers people rather than be
like you were so wrong look totally no
be like look how bet much better off we
are now that the truth is apparent
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time